el gigante gasístico gazprom el
principal proveedor de gas de europa ha
anunciado que cierra el gasoducto no res
tribuno el principal gasoducto que nutre
de gas al continente europeo la razón
que ha esgrimido
moscú es que ha encontrado un problema
técnico una fuga de aceite en una de las
principales turbinas pero el anuncio se
produce sólo horas después de que el ex
presidente ruso y actual número 2 del
consejo de seguridad de mipyme 10
amenazas a europa con cerrar el grifo
del gas si seguían adelante los planes
de fijar un tope para el gas ruso el
anuncio de gazprom no incluye una fecha
en la que se reabriría este caso ducto y
sorprende a los mercados europeos en un
momento en el que se estaban
aprovisionando de gas para tener los
depósitos llenos de cara a un invierno
que va a ser muy incierto con la
prolongación de la guerra en ucrania